the worst moment in russia's naval
history since world war ii
its long-serving flagship sunk with it
russian pride and its perception of
naval invincibility in the black sea
it's a boost for those defending
odessa's shores
i believe that our army can do
everything
and
as you saw russian
great army is not great army
and we have great people and great
soldiers and we're ready to defend
ourselves
the moskva was built 70 kilometers up
the coast from here in the ukrainian
town of mikhail and it was authorities
here in odessa who were first to say
that it had been struck by two ukrainian
neptune missiles ultimately sending it
to the bottom of the sea
moscow claims it sank after a fire it's
not clear how many of the 500 crew were
killed but ukraine claimed that the
captain was among the dead odessa is
just glad it's gone everybody's talking
about this and
we are really happy everybody
celebrating i want to believe that our
at least this location odessa and the
odessa region will be a little bit safer
because that's one of the
worship that was
threatening us
commissioned during the cold war the
moskva was fitted with anti-ship and
anti-aircraft missiles
there's speculation that nuclear
warheads might have gone down with it
that would mean a big recovery operation
for russia
but the flagship's loss is also a
strategic headache
it also warns them that they've got to
stand off the ukrainian coast a bit
further because they didn't take
ukrainian missile capabilities seriously
because they hadn't seen them before and
now they will be worried about the
neptune missiles they don't know and we
don't know how many of these the
ukrainians have got
the last satellite images show the
moskva dwarfing two other ships in
crimea's port of sevastopol on the 7th
of april then at sea on the 10th but the
moment it entered the theater of war in
late february it became a symbol of
ukrainian mockery
at snake island the warship tannoyed
ukrainian soldiers to surrender to avoid
bloodshed their defiant expletive
response is now so famous it doesn't
need repeating but it inspired this
ukrainian postage stamp
russia was keen to show it still has
devastating firepower its military
releasing video it says are cruise
missiles bound for keeve
and a drive through mariopol shows what
russia will do to achieve what it calls
liberation
ukraine says the southern city was hit
today for the first time by long-range
missiles as moscow threatens to bring
more of this to ukraine's villages towns
and cities in the weeks to come
jason farrell sky news odessa